we have startling new information in the
battle against the opioid epidemic a
newly released report says the Food and
Drug Administration may have failed to
set strict enough standards and
follow-through for training doctors
about the risks associated with the
highly addictive drugs researchers say a
lack of oversight and training problems
happened while the opioid crisis killed
tens of thousands of people a year our
consumer investigative correspondent and
a Warner is here and what exactly are
these rules and how were they supposed
to work well good morning Jericka those
rules part of an FDA process it's called
a risk evaluation and mitigation
strategy or REMS
it required manufacturers of long-acting
addictive opioids like oxycontin to pay
for training for doctors prescribing
those drugs then to monitor and report
back on how well that training was
working but in the new study researchers
found that didn't happen it basically
controlled my life
Jennifer why song became addicted to
opioids after having a c-section an
addiction that eventually landed her
behind bars every single day when I woke
up my main focus was wake up and figure
out a way to get what I needed to just
get through the day I didn't care who I
hurt or you know what I had to do to get
it
her story is not uncommon the Centers
for Disease Control and Prevention says
in 2017 opioids were involved in more
than 65 percent of all drug overdose
deaths
the report says long-acting or
extended-release opioids such as
oxycodone and morphine were associated
with greater risk of addiction
unintentional overdose and death than
their immediate release counterparts so
in 2012 the FDA set up rules requiring
painkiller manufacturers to deliver
continuing education to doctors and
develop medication guides to inform
patients about risks as well as monitor
and report on patient access to drugs
and safety but the problem says some
experts was that the FDA let the
pharmaceutical companies themselves
create the curriculum dr. Andrew Kalani
is medical director for opioid Policy
Research at Brandeis University
one of the problems is that the
education is voluntary the other problem
was simply the content that was a
curriculum design by the drug makers a
curriculum that didn't really discourage
aggressive prescribing researchers at
Johns Hopkins University found in their
review of thousands of fda documents
that the agency failed to follow up on
problems with the program and never
insisted on changes to address those
problems so what do you think for the
consequences of this so the consequences
were that at a time when the CDC and
other public health groups across the
country were trying to get doctors to
prescribe more cautiously the FDA had a
training program for doctors that was
encouraging more aggressive prescribing
this was making it more difficult to
tackle the opioid crisis in a statement
to CBS News the FDA says the opioid
tragedy is a defining public health
crisis and the REMS program is one
element in a broader national effort to
stem the tide of addiction in
communities Jennifer why song is now
clean and sober but wonders if that
training program could have made a
difference if they could know what we
know now back then things might have
been a little bit different the CDC does
lay out guidelines for proper opioid
prescription those include evaluating
the need for pain medications proper
selection of the right drug and
accessing the risk or explaining the
risk of addiction explaining those risks
to the patient but it wasn't until 2017
that the FDA began requiring safety
programs for all opioid painkillers and
not just these long-acting ones they
looked at here so and in the piece you
talk about the pharmaceutical companies
writing the curriculum that's what
doctors well FDA allowing them that's
what that's what dr. kolodny said the
FDA didn't respond to questions about
that but he basically believes that the
influence of manufacturers played a part
here that they didn't want to lose sales
yeah and you know that's his opinion
obviously as an expert and the
researchers seem to comment on that as
well certainly hoping the FDA does a
better oversight there
Kyoya
you